just a quick note before we get started
this episode contains some profanity so
if you have kids in the car or if you
yourself are offended by bad words then
you may want to go ahead and skip this
episode or listen to it later otherwise
we really hope you enjoy this episode of
the minimalists podcast this episode of
the minimalists is brought to you by did
we get a sponsor yet no there's some
emails out but I haven't heard anything
but I just kidding this episode is 100%
advertisement free because
advertisements suck we hope you enjoy
the show every little thing you think
that's mean every little thing you think
that you need every little thing that's
just feeding your greed oh I bet that
you'll be fine without it
hello everybody and welcome it to the
minimalists podcast where we discuss
what it means to live a meaningful life
with less less stuff less stress less
discontent less anxiety but a whole lot
more meaning my name is Joshua fields
Millburn and i am ryan nicodemus and
we're the minimalist indeed and this is
episode number 4 of the minimalists
podcast and today you know we're going
to talk about education and everything
that that sort of involves whether its
job or career or mission or passion or
creativity we're going to talk about
that by answering some of your voicemail
questions and social media questions but
first this morning Ryan what did you do
this morning I had some delicious fresh
ground coffee yeah yeah and yeah it was
it was a pretty rush rush to get here to
do this well this I guess this in a
weird way is our work and it's also
education for us we're relatively new to
the whole podcasting genre
and we are utterly ignorant to being
able to do this so we're grateful that
so many tens of thousands I guess
hundreds of thousands of people are now
listening to this podcast but it's a
huge growth experience for us we spent
the last five years as the minimalists
and we've done a bunch of things that
really helped us grow educated ourselves
in ways that are a bit non-traditional
and so we want to be able to share those
with you and discuss those with you
today and I guess we could begin with
today's voicemail questions we have we
have one we can start with Cecilia their
minimalist approach to getting a decent
college education and here's one from
brandy I really feel like colleges
starting to during my soul and I'm just
not living the life that I think I
should be I would really love to become
a tattoo artist now that's what that
path seems so risky though since you
know you had to go through the long
process of finding an apprenticeship and
building your technical technical skills
and everything well I think I would
really be willing to put in the work
it's just it's really scary to go off
that quote-unquote you know safe path of
being in college and getting that high
paying job with that great degree that
you earned my question to you guys is
how do I summon the courage to say you
know what no I'm not going to do what
society expects me to do and I'm going
to pursue something that will actually
add a lot of value to my life and that
in my case it's tattooing thank you
brandy we have a similar question or I
guess a related question from Elise on
Facebook Brian you want to read that yes
Elise
writes why is it so easy to get caught
up in the rat race vibe from friends it
almost feels like you should settle for
something you don't want well I've been
there before
Amen me too so you know I guess we
should go ahead and talk about this
let's start with with Cecilia she
basically just said is there a
minimalist approach to getting a decent
education and where I would start is you
have to define what a decent education
is
and we've written about this topic
before on our website and I'd love to to
read a little bit of an excerpt from one
of our essays this is from our book
essential essays which has 12 different
themes on or told different approaches
of how you can apply minimalism to your
life and one of the chapters in there is
about passion and another chapter in
there is about success so I'd like to
send a copy of that book to Cecilia also
to brandy and Elise so they can have
they can arm themselves with some tools
to help them through their process of
deciding what's right for them but this
essay is called unti choose the more
experienced we are the more unlearning
we have to do we entered this world as
creators curious to discover ways to
express ourselves visually auditorily
kinesthetically
but over time we are taught to be more
realistic to be safe to be reasonable to
be normal when in truth we never wanted
to be safe or reasonable maybe we wanted
to be normal but today's normality
template is far from what most of us had
in mind at age five growing up we all
just wanted to be ourselves that was
normal but soon we were placed in a
classroom told to stand in line and
speak when spoken to and prescribed ADHD
ADHD medication if we got out of line
this methodically worked great for
creating factory workers and farmers
which seemed ideal when 90% of the
population was either the former or the
latter today however most people are
neither factory workers nor farmers and
even those positions have changed
radically in the past few decades and
yet we're all graced with the assembly
line mentality systematically programmed
for compliance expected to adhere to
external standards while disregarding
whatever our own internal normal was
during this process our creativity is
quashed and replaced with a vast
emptiness
a desire to create even though we're
told that we're not creative it's no
coincidence that we started focusing
more on consuming around the same time
looking for any material thing to fill
the void all children are artists the
problem is how to remain an artist once
he grows up Picasso had this observation
a century ago and unfortunately these
words ring even truer in today's
post-industrial world a world where our
vocations no longer ate the form of
pseudo creation a la farming and factory
Inge and thus the gap between creation
and consumption widens as we attempt to
buy what no one can possibly sell
individual creativity the strange thing
about this antiquated system is that
most of its gatekeepers government
officials school administrators and
teachers aren't operating out of malice
if anything the reaction is birthed from
apathy or comfort or both many teachers
in fact are just as disenchanted with
the whole mess as we are though they
often feel like just another faceless
cog in the wheel powerless amongst the
tyranny of bureaucracy thankfully there
are alternatives for children
there's homeschooling and unschooling
and wonderful programs like 826 Valencia
and for adults the options are endless
there are books and blogs and classes
and conferences plus there are scores of
people like us the minimalists people
who have rejected the system and aligned
their lives with their values and
beliefs people who function not as
teachers but as unteach helping people
unlearn the [ __ ] they've acquired
over the years so that they too can
become unti choose and help further the
spread of creativity and ideas of course
none of these alternatives are easy per
se but then again it is way too easy to
stand in line to Rea
and when we want to speak to blindly
follow authority to capitulate and above
all to comply [ __ ] that the easy route
is easy because it's a vacuum devoid of
meeting it's vacant it also lacks
innovation and beauty and all the
unspeakable qualities that makes life
exhilarating and worth living naturally
the scenic route takes longer to travel
but the experience is worth it to
traverse the windy coastline takes more
time sure but so does anything worth
pursuing amen
you know I think it's interesting we've
in a weird way become rot Ryan and
myself we've become on teachers yeah
it's crazy I mean you you teach a
writing class III mentor I have no
official degree in psychology or therapy
or anything like that you have no degree
in teaching I've never taken a writing
class in my life but I'm really
passionate about writing write I mean
really I coerce people into taking a
writing class and then once they're in
and I trick them and say you know what
it's not actually writing class it's a
habit-forming class and there are some
tips in here to help you with your
writing and how to write better I mean
that's the name of the course but but
it's not about just learning shortcuts
there are no shortcuts right there are
direct routes to doing what what you
want to do so Cecilia is there a decent
minimalist approach to education well it
depends on what you mean by by education
I I think sometimes a formal degree is
important I personally wouldn't go to a
dentist who was a DIY dentist right yeah
if I'm getting brain surgery I hope that
surgeon went to college yeah absolutely
and it's because those systems those
structures are best set up to ensure
that those people know what they are
doing however there are many other times
where it is not necessary to seek a a
traditional
and so maybe we should we should talk
about about some of those scenarios when
when it may or may not be responsible or
applicable or appropriate for you to to
seek the traditional route yeah I mean
first and foremost if I was to ever go
back to college which I am totally open
to that one day we had a question on our
Tuesday's with the minimalist where
someone asked like would you ever
consider going to college if I did it
would be it would be more of pursuing a
hobby type thing like I'd go for acting
or I'd go for physics something that I
was really interested in or that I
wanted to learn more about but I would
never do that if I was going to go back
into debt that is one thing that I
really hoped and I'm 100% debt free and
I hope to stay that way I'll just cut
you off there I think I think there's no
such thing as good debt and and that
that's one thing to to be really
concerned about when we're approaching
approaching continuing our education we
often assume that we have to go into
these massive amounts of debt and if you
have to go the traditional route you're
going to go to a college well there's
some things you can consider you can
consider a community college especially
for the first two years of a traditional
bachelor's degree you should certainly
consider something that's in-state with
because the in-state rates are generally
appreciably lower and you should also
consider finding ways to fund your way
through college while you're going
through it as opposed to taking on soon
dead that will prohibit you from living
the life that you want to live because
you're going to be tied to an income
that you need just to pay back those
student loans yeah I was going to say I
would even argue that like you could go
to you could go to school for free right
now even without spending the money even
without having to worry about the money
because what I was going to say is I am
taking classes online right now just
kind of randomly at my leisure for free
they are on like quantum physics
something like really silly but just
something that I want to go down the
rabbit hole a little bit with and I can
do that for free and get some really
good classes and like right now I could
totally have a decent conversation with
you about
about quantum physics and when I say
decent I know you could probably a
little bit less than decent I don't know
anything about it you're very one-sided
question but I could also go and learn
about quantum physics or I could go
improve my writing online there are a
lot of different things I can do online
in a very non-traditional sense and I
mean we have this this in this infinite
amount of information that is at our
literally at our fingertips right now
whether it's in our pocket or on our
computer screen or wherever and instead
we spend a lot of time focusing on
incessantly checking our emails or or
just getting caught in the Bermuda
Triangle of social media as opposed to
using the technology to enhance our
lives to improve our lives to learn and
to grow and and what we're really
talking about here with education is I
want to grow as an individual well why
do you want to grow it so you can
contribute to the world around you and
the more you grow the more you have to
give and so does that mean you have to
go through a traditional education
setting if you want to I'm not saying
there's anything inherently wrong with
it I don't see a reason to do it for for
most vocation these days well I mean
let's yeah let's go to to brainy look
talk about her situation specifically so
the one of the first things that stood
out to me she said that she felt like it
was draining her soul now yes now that
to me is a flag right and that's why she
called him cuz that's a huge flag sure
this feels like it's draining my soul I
gotta leave now here's what I would
challenge Brandi to do is to really look
at the result
look at her outcome that she is going to
get after going to college she said that
she really wants to be a tattoo artist
she loves to paint she loves to draw is
she taking classes right now for
painting and drawing is that helping her
painting and drawing career or she in
there for marketing if it is for
painting and drawing the question that
needs to be asked is is this painful or
is this uncomfortable and there is a
difference right yes indeed I mean if if
you are in pain we know when you're
working out
you know the difference between like an
uncomfortable getting that last rep out
and oh my goodness my shoulder hurts I
have to put the weight down yeah this
comfor if we're in a place of discomfort
that is the place from which we grow
absolutely
so the question needs to be asked here
with brandy is do do you need to push
through this discomfort to grow and if
the answer is yes then I would say maybe
consider staying in college if the
answer is no by the time I graduate
college I'm going to have a marketing
degree that I'm not going to do anything
with then yeah I would consider maybe
going an alternative route yeah and that
alternative route you know you mentioned
a few things that there's the stigma of
of leaving college well
stigma with who I mean if you're hanging
out with people who are discouraging you
from cultivating a passion because you
really enjoy and are excited about the
prospect of some sort of artistic career
and it sounds like being a tattoo artist
is is maybe the terminus of that for you
and I think that's really exciting if
you can cultivate that excitement turn
it into a passion because it's not
something you're yet passionate about
you won't actually be passionate about
that brandy until you're willing to put
in the many many many hours of drudgery
so that you get to the other side you
get the actual payoff of becoming a
phenomenal tattoo artist where you feel
just great about what you're doing and
you get excited about being able to do
new work and while you're in it in the
moment sometimes it may seem mundane
sometimes it may seem overwhelming and
you may hit these these plateaus where
you feel like you're not growing but you
have to keep you have to keep working
through that in order to really
cultivate it into a passion that you
wake up in the morning and you feel good
about about doing what you're doing as
opposed to the opposite instead of the
opposite by the way of pain isn't
pleasure the obverse side of the coin is
comfort comfort is the other side of
pain and you know what I can either feel
comfort or discomfort discomfort lets me
know
that I'm growing that's one of the
reasons we're doing this this podcast
now is it's another opportunity for us
to grow not necessarily grow our
audience or anything like that but I
would say I'm not very great at speaking
and having these sorts of sorts of
conversations repeatedly but it's
allowed me to build that muscle it's a
long ryan to build that muscle so over
time we get good at it and if you're
still tuning in here a hundred episodes
from now
I plan to be appreciably better at
having these types of conversations yeah
absolutely and you know going back to
that stigma of being a dropout you know
right now it sounds like brandy is
associating her identity with being a
college student and I know that when I
was in the corporate world I associated
my identity with my job I was also going
to college so I guess I was identifying
as a college student someone as well but
I will say that letting go of my
identity that's that's one of the
hardest parts so I don't want to just
blow over that and be like well you know
just don't don't care don't care about
the stigma letting go of that identity
is definitely difficult but if it is
going to get you to the other side of
it's going to get you farther down that
path closer to building your brand
towards tattoo artists ting then then
that is that's exactly what you should
do let's talk about why we have that
identity though I mean what's what's the
first question when you meet someone new
what's the first thing they ask what do
we do what do you do what a [ __ ]
terrible question we we ask this
question these four words we don't
realize how dangerous they are I think
that's life's most dangerous question
and it's not that someone is malicious
when they come up to you and say hey
Ryan what do you do and it's like I got
your question gotcha I have to ask you
what you do and think about that
question for a minute though what we're
really asking isn't what do you do
because that's such an expansive
question when I say what do you ask me
what do you do I can say a bunch of
things well I check email I drink water
I walk I exercise I enjoy going a long
walks on the beach it these are all
things that I do but what we're really
saying is hey where do you work what's
your job title how much
money do you make so I can compare you
to me on the socio-economic ladder but
if you ask the question that way you
seem like a real jerk and so instead we
just say what do you do and then we're
supposed to tell the person what our job
title is and and much like like you Ryan
I you know I hadn't a very impressive
I'm saying that with vocal quotes here
for those of you listening and an
impressive job title so I did impressive
answer to that question for a very long
time when someone said what do you do
and I was 27 years old I would say I'm
the director of operations for a hundred
and fifty retail stores and and then I
would you know just pare it back the
question to them what do you do and that
would allow me to understand should I
associate with this person are they the
ideal and networking companion can base
what we're saying is how can I use this
person to you know further my status or
or or improve my own life in some way
and it's a terrible way to think about
other human beings as some sort of
object that I can use and so that was a
problem for me because I had that
impressive answer and I found the way to
change that from what do I do what is my
job title and then spending the next 20
minutes talking to someone about oh
here's my job title what do you do to
earn money and not really be that
interested in the conversation it's not
that I had a bad job that I hated it and
necessarily hate it I was comfortable in
it and I was working 80 hours a week and
I what didn't have time to pursue what I
actually wanted to pursue I sure I
certainly wasn't passionate about what I
was doing and so in order to change my
identity I had to change that question
so when someone said what do you do I
would say I'm really passionate about
writing and and people kind of look at
me and say oh you're a writer and we'll
see I never said I was a writer I call
it turning a noun into a verb I didn't
say I'm a writer because if you say
you're a writer or if you say you're a
tattoo artist so you say you're whatever
what what you're really saying is this
is how I make a living and and so I sent
passionate about writing and people say
Oh
and I said what are you passionate about
because if I were to say I'm a writer
you get the accusatory questions people
start saying things like well who's your
publisher
what's your agents name how many books
have you published have you written
anything that I would have read well no
not unless you read my journal because
there's no reason for me to make a
living off of something I'm necessarily
passionate about I was passionate about
writing because it was something I
really enjoyed doing and I cultivated
that into a passion over time and now
several books later I am I am able to
make a living off of that but that's not
what I set out to do I set out to do it
because it was something I was really
passionate about and finally I was able
to marry that with a way to earn a
living so that I can I can do both but I
encourage people to flip that question
around if you really want to lose the
identity of I'm a college student or on
the director of operations or I am a
barista or whatever
there's nothing wrong with those job
titles but they're not who you are as a
person you were so much more and so flip
that question say I'm really passionate
about X and then say what are you
passionate about and it will change the
trajectory of your conversations if
you're willing to make yourself
uncomfortable and have that conversation
it's easy to tell people the title on
your business card it's much harder to
talk about what you are truly passionate
about now some of you say I don't know
what I'm passionate about well we hear
this advice all the time you should
follow your passion you can walk over to
your local University I bet it's on some
sort of successor II poster poster right
now it says follow your passion and and
I think that is terrible advice in fact
we have a friend Cal Newport who wrote a
whole book about this called
so good they can't ignore you and and
his whole thesis there is follow your
passion is shitty advice and we've we've
had several conversations with Cal in
the past he's a professor over at
Georgetown University and ultimately we
need to take that advice a follow your
passion and throw it away because you
don't have a passion you weren't born to
be a yoga
teacher or an astronaut or a writer or a
barista or an accountant there are
dozens of things that you can be
passionate about and brandy for you it
sounds like one of those things is being
a tattoo artist the key then isn't to
follow your passion it's to find one
thing that aligns with your values that
aligns with your interests and your
desires and spend a lot of hard work and
time and dedication and blood sweat and
tears cultivating that interest into a
passion and over the years that may
change over time but you want to focus
on one thing now and really dive all the
way into it yeah and we're not just like
promoting Cal Newport here for the sake
of it but he just came out with another
book called deep work and I'm just going
to read a paragraph off his blog here
about it it says the book argues that
deep work focusing without distraction
on a cognitively demanding task is
becoming more valuable in our economy at
the same time that it's becoming more
rare and I could not agree with that
more if if brandy here is willing to
drop out of college and put in that deep
work to be a tattoo artist there is no
doubt that she will be successful to a
certain level I mean I'm not going to
say that she's going to be the best
tattoo artist in the world or become a
millionaire but I do know that when
people put in that deep work and they
stay focused that they will get some
great results and you know one other
thing I want to talk about is brandy
mentioned something about staying in
college because it's the safe path to a
large paying job or a high salary job
and that is not the case these days if
you're banking on getting a high paying
job just because you have a college
degree there there are some cases where
that happens but there's a stat that
says you know there are 44 percent of
graduates that are under employed
meaning that almost half of the graph
students are in a job that doesn't
require a college degree
I know in Portland they had a you know
huge article about this briefs the job
that posted and they had you know
hundreds of masters and Doctorate
degrees uh applying for this for this
barista position so I'm not saying again
that college is necessarily wrong um
there are some great stats that will say
that colleges is amazing um yeah I think
part of that is the average the average
person with the a college education over
his or her lifetime does make
considerably more money than just a high
school graduate me myself I'm only a
high school graduate in fact I tried to
drop out of high school and and my
counselor wouldn't let me talk to me out
of it the last year of school and and I
end up going to taking some college
classes afterward but never never
finished college and in here's here's
the thing yes the average person who
graduates from college will make more
money over his or her lifetime than the
average person who doesn't here's the
problem that I have with that statistic
is if you're basing your life off of the
average person's life you're probably
not going to be happy because the
average person especially in the United
States especially in the developed world
the average person is not happy the
average person is not living a
meaningful life I want to be anything
but average Brandee you also mentioned
it might be difficult for you to find an
apprenticeship and and there's that
stigma of I can tell you people said
this to me all the time I walked away
from the corporate world and people
didn't believe me when I was walking
away from the corporate world I I was
leaving and and people asked me like
what competitor you go into like I know
you said you're gonna be a writer but
come on man where are you going can you
take me with you and I said no I can't I
don't really have anywhere to take you
I'm just gonna go right and they're like
yeah but if but if if everyone could
make money as a writer than everyone
would be doing it and I'm like well
yeah but there are actually plenty of
people who earn a living writing I mean
it's not like there's this mythical job
of a writer that no one has ever
attained there are thousands of people
tens of thousands of people who who
aren't a living from whatever way and so
Brandi I'm going to send you a copy of
our very first book it's called
minimalism live a meaningful life and
the reason I'm going to send you a copy
of it is we have a whole chapter in
there about passions and careers and and
one of the things that we recommend is
you know if you've identified what you
want to cultivate into a passion and for
you that's being a tattoo artist or
someone else it might be an astronaut
for someone else it might be a teacher
there are paths to get there and and
really there's a model you can follow
someone else's recipe and so is there
are there people right now who are
making a living as a tattoo artist well
yes I know a few actually I don't have
any tattoos myself but I know people uh
like like Paul and Ben Brittany out and
in Oakland yeah I mean who make a really
phenomenal
I mean six-figure living from from doing
tattoos and and well that's great that
he makes good money that's not the point
of it the point is he's able to support
himself doing something he's really
passionate about and so you can find
people who do something they're
passionate about and have cultivated
that into a passion you find out what
their recipe is well how do you do that
well just like anything else if you have
a baker who has a recipe you have to you
have to set him or her down and figure
out exactly how they make the cake that
they make what ingredients they use what
sequence with temperature and you have
to do the same thing with whatever your
profession is and so we have a whole
recipe for modeling someone else in our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
so brandy I'd love to send you a copy of
that and hopefully you can you can
identify what recipe works for you and
then you adjust it to suit your own
tastes and incorporate your own
ingredients and develop it into your own
passion over a period of time so you can
take several other people's recipes and
make your own recipe and that's what
Ryan and I did
with with minimalism when we started
letting go of stuff we saw all these
different template templates of people
were living a a minimalist life but it
wasn't how we wanted to live our lives
necessarily in fact I have a different
template than Ryan and I think that's
why this works so well people find value
and in both of our different stories and
my recipe may not work for you
specifically but certainly you can tweet
out a few ingredients and create your
own recipe and you can do that same
thing with the work world with the world
of job and career and passion and while
we're on that very few of us get to this
thing that we call our mission in life
our our mission is the confluence of
what we're passionate about and also
being able to earn a living from it so
that we're able to focus on it more my
initial intention when I left the
corporate world was just to work at a
coffee shop and make enough money to pay
my bills so I could write fiction
hopefully one day after cultivating that
passion maybe I'd make some money off of
it but if not I was always going to do
it because I really enjoy writing and so
if you can find a way to take what
you're passionate about and not have
just a job and certainly not have a
career in fact for those of you out
there who are thinking about setting up
your long term career goals I think
that's so dangerous careers are
comfortable and comfort is not a place
from which we grow it's a place from
which we atrophy over time and if you're
not growing you're dying and so we have
an opportunity here to turn our lives
into something that we are passionate
about we're able to live our mission and
I would encourage you to figure out what
that is and and all to ultimately
cultivate that now I just want to tell
the listeners here about one catch to
living your mission or I'll say living
the dream you know I get I get mentoring
clients all the time who I will sit with
and like I want to do what you do I want
to I want to be a writer and I want to
do exactly what you do my first response
is usually you probably don't want to do
what I do
I have gone on 100 city tours I have to
leave my my my lovely lovely girlfriend
and very with very short notice
sometimes to go I do a speaking or
something like that now the result that
I get from all of this work is wonderful
and drudging through all this drudgery
is is a great experience
and luckily I have a supportive partner
who helps me to you know to get through
all of this and we work together but my
point is is that living the dream the
catch is is you have to work really
really hard no matter what so in if
you're if brandy there is willing to put
in the work then I would I would
encourage her to to at least maybe give
College a break yeah I mean and here's
the thing
brandy ultimately what Ryan said earlier
I would just expand on this what is your
outcome if if your outcome is to do
something that you are passionate about
do you need college to do that some
people the answer is yes I'm a really
good friend who's going to med school
right now in Tennessee and and she wants
to be a doctor who does like Doctors
Without Borders and works for charities
and not that she only become a doctor to
be to become rich in fact she's going to
issue that side of things
just so she can help people throughout
the world and man that is commendable
but she does need to go through all of
med school in order to do that and that
talk about drudgery oh my goodness but
the payoff for her is is important so
you have to think about what your
outcome is brandy and
in the book I recommended earlier
essential essays we have we have a whole
plan in there for identifying what your
outcome is and how to get that outcome
one last thing I'm going to recommend to
Cecilia hey because her question was
just about getting a decent education is
there is one of my favorite nonfiction
writers certainly my favorite blogger of
all time Seth Godin he wrote a manifesto
it's called stop stealing dreams and you
can get that at stop stealing dreams
calm it's basically a free I know it's
movie Fifty 70 page book he also has a
video and some other materials there at
stop stealing dreams calm that will take
you over to his blog and he talks about
how our society has changed and how
education isn't broken it's just out of
date and it's just like you wouldn't say
that the horse and buggy is broken but
you don't see anyone riding down your
street in a horse and buggy and and so
our education system much of it at least
not all of it necessarily but much of it
is antiquated and we have seen this
firsthand now Ryan you have a business
degree yes but it's not that you needed
that business degree in fact when you
were going to get that business degree I
remember like you were you were learning
Konza the names of concepts of things
you had implemented in the business
world half a decade prior yeah it was
wild it was like okay that's why this
technique that I use that I use works or
yeah this is what this technique is
called it's it was a definitely a filler
I did it so I could have that piece of
paper and I have it now and I haven't
used it I probably won't end up using it
I'm not again we're not saying that no
one should go to college we're just
talking about you know look at it with
your situation view college as a tool
and if it's a tool you can use it you're
going to get a benefit out of that's
great I didn't that doesn't mean that
you can't but seriously ask yourself
those questions what is your outcome and
and that that should help you make some
good
and no matter what I personally refuse
to go back into debt I spent the first
31 years of my life in debt I'll never
go back into debt again and I would
encourage you actually I would
discourage you from going to college if
it's going to force you to to acquire a
bunch of or any any real debt there are
ways to go to put yourself through
college if that is the route you have to
take without without racking up massive
amounts of debt and at least to answer
your question why at least on Facebook
facebook.com slash the minimalists she
wrote why is it so easy to get caught up
in the rat race vibe from friends
because you have surrounded yourself
with the wrong friends and and I used to
also have that same group of friends
very very type-a everyone I surrounded
myself with in the corporate world was
constantly part of that rat race here's
the problem with the rat race even if
you win the rat race at the end of the
day you are still a rat and so the best
piece of advice I ever got was from my
friend Jamar in Cincinnati he said you
can't change the people around you but
you can change the people around you and
what that really means is you can't try
to fix the people in your life but you
can surround yourself with more
supportive people who are going to prop
you up as opposed to leave you behind in
the rat race you can step off of the the
hamster wheel so to speak and move on to
something that is more meaningful and
the best way to do that is surround
yourself with awesome supportive people
if you don't have any people locally you
can also try our free local meetup
groups over at minimalist org we have
set up 100 free local meetup groups in
eight cities I'm sorry eight countries
100 cities eight countries and find some
people locally who we're willing to talk
to you about career and education and
decluttering and everything else so give
them a try if we don't have a meetup
group in your area yet don't worry we
have an online city with hundreds or
thousands of people I guess at this
point who can help support you through
whatever journey you are going through
and of course we would love to hear what
you all have to say feel free to give us
a call I had four zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine if you have tips
about education about pursuing your
passion about pursuing your job any
minimalism tips that you might have
we'll post some of our favorites or list
some of our favorite comments and tips
on the next episode and if we do select
your voicemail we'll give you an
autographed copy of one of our books
ultimately I think I think Ryan we
should probably talk about it what is
the idea of success here because there's
an undertone of of success we were here
like he's a successful person or she is
a successful person and our society now
our culture now has defined success as
the amassing of trinkets do you have the
larger house do you have the nicest
possible car do you have the position on
your job title we have these little
trophies along the way and we fill our
houses and our basements and our
entertainment rooms with all of these
trophies of success and while there
isn't anything inherently wrong with
individual material possessions
consumption isn't the problem
compulsory consumption is the problem we
keep trying to amass more stuff into our
void but it does not close the void it
widens it and so for us I think success
is a bit different from what it used to
be yeah I mean now I look at success a
couple different ways we have we have an
equation that we wrote in an essay a
while ago happiness plus constant
improvement plus contribution equals
success and that is certainly success
for me and I know Josh is that that is
success for you the reason why these
things are successful for me though is
because those qualities those things
that I focus on that those are what my
long-term values and beliefs
and if my short-term actions are
aligning with my long-term values and
beliefs for me that is success for me
that's that that's also that can be
happiness as well but yeah certainly a
success used to be something much much
different to me and and now you know
it's nice to have a formula that I don't
have to look to for money I don't have
to look to for I mean certainly we need
some security we all need to spend money
but but you know there isn't a physical
item there isn't a monetary idea behind
success for me anymore it does not take
a ton for me to be successful in a
recent magazine interview with with
People magazine the reporter asked me
who I thought of when I heard the word
successful and and my answer wasn't
Steve Jobs or Bill Gates or or Kim
Kardashian I really don't think of the
American Dream the old American Dream as
as the definition of success either when
when I think of success I think of my
friend Jamar who I mentioned a moment
ago he he's an outstanding father he's a
husband he's a high school teacher he's
a real estate investor and I don't think
it's those things that make him
successful what what makes him
successful is he's living what I would
call the new American dream he's happy
he's healthy he's debt-free he has full
control of his life and I feel like he
doesn't derive his self-worth from all
of these external factors and so I think
all of those things are will make him
the most successful person I know and
and Ryan the equation you gave earlier
that's the only kind of success I know
are you happy are you constantly growing
are you contributing to the world around
you and by the way those three things
all lead to each other if you're
contributing to the world you're going
to feel happier if you make someone else
happy that makes you happy
it also helps you
the more you grow the more you have to
give the more you give the happier other
people are and that makes you happier
and it's this beautiful beautiful cycle
and and so if you're really looking to
figure out what success is don't count
on a paycheck for that I know plenty of
millionaires who are miserable so
miserable there's nothing wrong with
earning money we're certainly not
allergic to money the thing is it is no
longer the primary focus of our lives
and it's certainly not my dream the old
American Dream is not my dream in the
millionaires I know who are happy they
would be happy without their Millions
yeah there's no doubt about it I agree
well let's let's play a few comments
from our last episode or last few
episodes the last episode was about
children we have some advice from some
readers and some listeners here at the
middle of spod cast hi my name is
Alexandra and I'm calling from st. Paul
Minnesota ah
because I had a few suggestions for
staying be cluttered with children or
being minimalist with children okay so
the first one is whenever my son sees an
advertisement I always remind him that
it's pretend and so the people are
pretending on their which is true
because they're paid actors also one
thing that my mother did when I was
younger with me and my younger brother
so when we were out of the store and
would ask for something my mom would say
that she needs to go to work first in
order to get money to buy that thing
so did we want to keep spending time
with my mom or did we want her to go to
work and by that same for us later and
we always chose to spend more time with
my mom so that sort of them filled the
value of time over money and time over
things for us as young children but
obviously if you're going to do this as
a parent you have to be able to follow
through if says that they want you to go
to work so what I do is my son whatever
to say tell me to go to work is how to
take him to a gym that provides free
childcare or something and just you know
I go work out or something but I still
the separation from him at any moment hi
my name is Gavin glass p.m. Ashley from
Toronto I don't know if you guys are
aware of this but the
especially I'm I study done in the UK I
think he's learned about 2010 and it was
- saying it like kids nowadays have on
average it was like 258 toys and they
used 12 them on a weekly basis 12 5 out
of 250 that by 5% or something which is
incredible on my waist my name is Jenny
and I'm from Columbia Missouri and I
have a suggestion for other grandparents
about simplifying Christmas I did this
several years ago in terms of
grandchildren
so for each grandchild we I designate a
certain amount of money in 2/3 so it
could be 3 $1 bills or 3 $5 bills
whatever your means and the instructions
are that they can take one-third and buy
whatever they want just blow it and the
second idea is that or the second
portion is that the say that put into
savings and then the third portion they
must donate pick a charity or
organization to donate because that's
the real meaning of the season okay
let's move on to our iTunes comment of
the week all right this one is called
easy listening bye
what do these benefit was like simple
listening simple ain't easy that's true
that is true this is by ski girl 2016
ski girl rights I guess I'm not
surprised that the minimalists could
produce such an easy to listen to
podcast it's like having a conversation
with an old friend they're thoughtful
and without provoking she calling old
lets you man you know you're you know
you're like eight months older than me
that's true no it's not like three
they're thoughtful and thought-provoking
and I'm so happy I have them to listen
to that is I love reading comments like
that I'm so happy that people are
getting value out of this because I
cannot stand my voice on the radio
I don't feel like I'm doing this very
well but hey other people think I am so
great I'm so happy to hear that you have
such a great radio voice I feel like you
could read movie trailers something do I
and in a world no seriously guys we
really appreciate those comments that is
that is awesome and we are so happy that
that so many of you are finding value in
this so keep those comments coming keep
them going
who is that left that come so that was a
ski girl 2016 ski girl 2016 well thank
you we will send you a copy of our book
my favorite book everything that remains
my favorite book that we've written not
my favorite book of all time by the way
just do us a favor once you have have
read that book pass it on to someone
else minimize the book give it someone
else who can find some value in it and
thank you to everyone else who has left
us a comment or a review on iTunes your
positive honest reviews helped our
simple living message
reach way more ears so we really
appreciate it we can do some
lightning-round hashtag ask the minimum
let's do it go we were we're at the
minimalists on Twitter and Instagram and
Facebook calm / the minimalist if you
want to do a lightning round question
for ask the minimalist Scott asks do you
ever read books that spark interest but
turns out that you found only sections
of the book to be useful yeah absolutely
you know I think that's a nice thing
about books these days is they can
necessarily be shorter I think of my
friend Julian who wrote an awesome book
called the flinch I would definitely
encourage you to check it out in fact we
didn't interview with him the
minimalists calm slash Flint it's a free
book too by the way I think it was free
house it's across Taiwan yeah I think
it's a couple bucks oh gods it's real
it's totally worth it even if it is just
a couple bucks all right we have one
more question we'll do this one from
reivew what is your opinion of women one
person I love them
next question yes no he says one person
is less than two and the less we have
the happier we are thoughts on solitude
I think Saul is it's very important
especially as an introvert
and but you can't treat other people as
things I mean that's kind of our tagline
one of my thoughts on on women it's like
asking what my thoughts are on white
people or what are my thoughts on senior
citizens we're all different I want to
surround myself with people who add
value to my life but I'm also able to
contribute to I think with any
relationship there is what I call an Us
box and we're happy only when we're able
to contribute as much as we can
contribute and we're able to get from
that that relationship something that
nurtures our lives as well and just
because I'm able to contribute more to
some relationships and less to others it
doesn't mean that it has to be 50/50 and
so I want you to think about that when
preview when you're considering
surrounding yourself with people yeah
solitude is great and I think it's
necessary especially for introverts in
fact I spend about 90% of my time alone
and you can read about that I've written
quite a bit about it but the essay to go
to there is the minimalists comm slash
alone and you can read about sort of my
myers-briggs and why solitude is so
important to me but when I do surround
myself with people I make sure that I'm
able to contribute to them and in fact
that's the best part of spending time so
much time alone is when I am there I am
really there and I go way out of my way
to show the people I love that I care
about them that I understand them and
I'll do what I can to support them okay
now let's move on to our added value
portion of the show this is where Ryan
and I recommend something that has added
value to our lives recently and because
we're talking about education today and
learning and careers and stuff like that
I'd love to talk to you about a book
that I found a lot of value in it's by
Daniel pink a lot of you have probably
heard about this book it's called Drive
and he talks about the the three things
that drive us to do meaningful work
and he has an amazing TED talk on this
topic as well so the full title of the
book with the subtitle is drive the
surprising truth about what motivates us
definitely check it out if you get a
chance I think you'll be surprised yes
and because we are on the topic of
Education this podcast I would like to
recommend webcast berkeley.edu that is
actually when I was talking about
earlier those quantum physics classes
that I just kind of take at my own
leisure I think I've gotten to like
maybe like six or seven of them there
they're there it's a very intuitive
sight to use and there are just hundreds
of classes to take online for free so
check that out if you are looking to
self educate yourself a little bit
finally let's move on to our our last
segment we call it right here right now
this is kind of what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists right when this
is airing when this podcast air is we
are will be in the middle of three days
three caffeinated days with the
minimalists in st. Petersburg Florida if
you want to come hang out with us we're
going to live our dream jobs as baristas
in st. Petersburg Florida for three days
we're doing a special charity event at a
brand new coffee shop that's opening an
awesome coffee shop called bandit coffee
so you can find all the details about
that at the minimalists comm slash
bandit we're also coming to the end of
our tuesdays with the minimalists on
periscope so you can check that out at
periscope TV slash the minimalists and
in just a couple weeks I have a special
how to write better one time class so I
teach a semester long online how to
write better class and it's very
in-depth requires a lot of attention and
focus from students if they really want
to get a lot of value from it but it's
the first time I've tried doing a one
time two-hour class where I give a
lesson alongside my adjunct professor
Sean Malik who helps out with a lot of
how to write better stuff and we're
going to answer your questions about how
to improve your writing the seats on
that will be limited but you can find
all of the details over at how to write
better done well
org also in the coming weeks you're
going to find out how we can how you can
rather bring our documentary
it's called minimalism a documentary
about the important things to your city
or suburb Ryan and I are going to hit
like 13 14 cities in May but then that's
the nice thing about having this
documentary which we're so proud of you
can go to minimalism film.com for
details we're going to make a big
announcement in February about how you
can get minimalism to play in your local
theater really really in a really easy
way and I think I think it's all we have
I hope you really found value in in this
episode and if I could give one piece of
advice to brandy before we leave and
this brandy just sort of serves as a
synecdoche for everyone else out there
so if you are in a situation like brandy
where you need to make a decision and
you need some permission I'm going to
say this brandy just [ __ ] do it
you're going to be so much happier on
the other side it's certainly not going
to be easy but a simple life is not
meant to be easy it's meant to be
meaningful and so to everyone else if
you leave here with with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works that's it for today's
episode Ryan you want to read all the
important bits of course of course the
minimalists podcast is produced by Sean
Harding and is recorded at the offices
of asymmetrical press our theme music
was written and performed by Peter Dorn
for more of Peters music visit the
minimalists comm slash Peter the podcast
is 100% advertisement free so if you
found value in this episode and you'd
like to help us keep it that way because
advertisements suck you guys know that
please visit the minimalists comm /
donate even if you just donate $1 we
really really appreciate it guys if you
have a question for the minimalists give
us a call at 4:06
to
one nine seven eight three nine if you'd
like to read more from the minimalists
you can subscribe to our essays for free
via email on our website the minimalists
com thanks for less than y'all we'll see
you next time every little thing you
think that's me every little thing you
think that you need every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh I bet
that you'll be fine without it every
little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without me
so tear your eyes oh gee